.
RICH: NOT BAD.
DAN SPRINGER IN PORTLAND,
OREGON, THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
JACQUI.
JACQUI: RICH, FOR MORE ON WHAT
ISSUES ARE IMPORTANT TO VOTERS
WITH MIDTERMS THREE WEEKS AWAY,
WE'RE JOINED BY CONGRESSWOMAN
FROM IOWA AND BUDGET
COMMITTEES, ASHLEY HINSON.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US,
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME.
THANKS, JACQUI FOR HAVING ME.
JACQUI: OF COURSE, I WANT TO
POP UP ON THE SCREEN JUST SOME
INFLATION DATA HERE AND WE CAN
DIVE INTO THE NUMBERS.
INFLATION IN SEPTEMBER HIT 8.2%
COMPARED TO LAST YEAR AND SOME
OF THOSE CATEGORIES ARE REALLY,
REALLY BAD.
EGGS UP MO ARE THAN 30%.
MILK MORE THAN 15%, FRUITS AND
VEGETABLES 10%.
COFFEE MORE THAN 15% AND THEN
THE MORE ALARMING DATA I THINK
FROM THE REPORT IF YOU STRIP
OUT THE VOLATILE FOOD AND
ENERGY COSTS, CORE CPI HIT A
40-YEAR HIGH 6.6%.
THE PRESIDENT ARGUED THAT HIS
POLICIES ARE WORKING THAT MONEY
FROM THE INFRASTRUCTURE LAW GOT
SUPPLY CHAINS WORKING AND THAT
SOME OF THE OTHER BILLS THEY'VE
PASSED WON'T TAKE EFFECT UNTIL
NEXT YEAR SO PEOPLE REALLY HAVE
TO WAIT TO SEE THE PRICES COME
DOWN.
TAKING OFF YOUR PARTISAN HAT
FOR JUST A MOMENT, IS THERE ANY
TRUTH TO THAT?
>> ABSOLUTELY NOT, JACQUI.
WHAT I'M HEARING FROM IOWANS AS
I'M OUT ON THE TRAIL IS THAT
THIS INFLATION IS TRULY A
PELOSI PAY CUT FOR IOWANS AND
AMERICANS.
WE CANNOT AFFORD ANOTHER TWO
YEARS LIKE THE LAST TWO.
WE'VE WARNED THE EXCESSIVE
SPENDING BINGE IN WASHINGTON
D.C. WOULD TRIGGER INFLATION,
DID THEY LISTEN?
ABSOLUTELY NOT.
THEIR SOLUTION WAS TO TAX MORE
AND SPEND MORE AND LOOK, YOU
CAN CALL ANYTHING, ANY BILL YOU
WANT, BUT THE SO-CALLED
INFLATION REDUCTION ACTS HIRES
87,000 NEW IRS AGENTS.
THE ONLY WAY TO PAY FOR THE
SPENDING THAT THE DEMOCRATS ARE
PUTTING FORTH IS TO TAX YOU
MORE AND TO COME AFTER
HARD-WORKING AMERICANS.
SO, THIS BIDEN-PELOSI AGENDA IS
SIMPLY WRONG THAT'S WHY I
BELIEVE THIS ELECTION WILL BE
ABOUT ACCOUNTABILITY.
THIS ELECTION IS ABOUT PUTTING
A CHECK ON THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION AND IT'S HIGH
TIME THAT WE TAKE THEIR
CHECKBOOK AWAY AND THAT'S WHAT
I'M HEARING ABOUT FROM IOWANS.
JACQUI: YOU FACED SOME
CRITICISM FROM YOUR OPPONENT IN
YOUR RACE FOR OPPOSING, FOR
INSTANCE, THE BIPARTISAN
INFRASTRUCTURE LAW, BUT
WELCOMING $829 MILLION IN
FUNDING TO BENEFIT YOUR
DISTRICT LOCALLY.
IS IT AT ALL HYPOCRITICAL TO
WELCOME THAT KIND OF MONEY
COMING BACK TO YOUR DISTRICT
AFTER VOTING AGAINST IT AND
GENERALLY OPPOSING SPENDING?
>> WELL, I THINK WHAT IT COMES
DOWN TO IS WOULD IOWANS WANT ME
TO LET THE MONEY GO ELSEWHERE,
TO NEW YORK OR CALIFORNIA?
WHEN I LOOKED AT THAT SPENDING,
IT WAS TRIGGERING RAMPANT
INFLATION ALREADY AT THAT POINT
IN THE YEAR AND THE DEMOCRATS
DIRECTLY TIED THAT
INFRASTRUCTURE BILL TO AT THE
TIME TRILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN
SOCIAL SPENDING SO I SAID, HEY,
I DON'T THINK THIS IS THE RIGHT
TIME TO SPEND THIS AMOUNT OF
MONEY, BUT IT PASSED ANYWAY.
SO MY JOB AS IOWA'S VOICE AND
IOWA'S RENT IS TO GET AS MANY
OF THOSE DOLLARS BACK TO IOWA
AS POSSIBLE AND THAT'S WHAT I
DID.
THE NEED IS THERE TO ENHANCE
OUR LOCK AND DAM SYSTEM ON THE
MISSISSIPPI RIVER, SO, IT WAS A
GREAT OPPORTUNITY FOR ME TO
WORK WITH PARTNERS ACROSS THE
RIVER AND ACROSS THE AISLE TO
MAKE SURE THE FUNDS WERE COMING
BACK TO BENEFIT MY DISTRICT,
BUT WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE AMOUNT
OF SPENDING THAT'S BEEN
HAPPENING OVER THE LAST 22
MONTHS, BOY, IT HAS PUT OUR
COUNTRY ON THE WRONG TRACK, SO
INFLATION IS OUT OF CONTROL,
THE ENERGY POLICIES, WHAT I'M
HEARING FROM FARMERS WHO ARE
NOT ONLY THE ULTIMATE
ENVIRONMENTALISTS, BUT THEY'RE
THE ULTIMATE CONSUMERS OF
ENERGY, THEY'RE USING DIESEL
AND FERTILIZER TO HELP FUEL AND
FEED THE WORD.
THEIR INPUT COSTS ARE UP 300%
AND THIS ADMINISTRATION
CONTINUES TO DOUBLEDOWN AND
SPEND MORE, THAT'S THE D.C.
WAY.
D.C. NEEDS TO OPERATE A LOT
MORE LIKE IOWA AND WHAT I'M
TRYING TO BRING FORTH IS COMMON
SENSE TARGETED IN THE COUNTRY.
JACQUI: IF THE DEMOCRATS TAKE
BACK CONGRESS THAT INFLATION IS
GOING TO GET WORSE.
I WANT TO PLAY THIS.
>> THEY WANT TO REPEAL THE
INFLATION REDUCTION ACT, REPEAL
THE $2,000 CAP ON PRESCRIPTION
DRUGS, GONE.
CAP ON INSULIN, GONE AT $35.
SAVING ON HEALTH CARE PREMIUMS
AVERAGE OF $400 A PERSON, GONE.
SAVINGS ON UTILITY BILLS, GONE.
JACQUI: NOW, I COVERED THE
WHITE HOUSE DURING THE WEEK, I
HADN'T HEARD THE PRESIDENT SAY
THAT YET.
DO REPUBLICANS WANT TO REPEAL
THE INFLATION REDUCTION ACT?
IS IT EVEN POSSIBLE?
YOU KNOW AS WELL AS I DO THAT
IT WAS PRETTY TOUGH TO UNDO
OBAMACARE, FOR INSTANCE, IS
THAT EVEN A PRACTICAL SOLUTION?
>> WELL, WE'RE LOOKING FOR REAL
SOLUTIONS NOT GOVERNMENT PRICE
FIXING SCHEMES, TO WHAT WHAT
THE PRESIDENT JUST SAID SOUNDS
A LOT LIKE SOCIALISM.
WHAT THEY'VE DONE WITH SPENDING
SPREE IS CONTINUING TO EXPAND
THE SIZE AND SCOPE OF
GOVERNMENT.
IOWANS TELL THEY WANT TO BE
RESPECTED BY THEIR GOVERNMENT
AND EMBRACE THEIR FREEDOM AND
THEY WANT A GOVERNMENT THAT
RESPECTS THAT.
SO WHAT WE WANT TO DO, AGAIN,
THIS IS ABOUT ACCOUNTABILITY IN
THE NEXT CONGRESS.
WHY WE NEED TO FIRE NANCY
PELOSI AND HOLD THIS PRESIDENT
ACCOUNTABLE IS BECAUSE IOWANS
ARE TIRED OF SEEING THEIR
PAYCHECKS DISRESPECTED BY
CONGRESS AND BY THE FOLKS IN
WASHINGTON D.C.
JACQUI: YOU DO OR DON'T WANT TO
REPEAL THE INFLATION REDUCTION
ACT.
I DIDN'T HEAR AN ANSWER.
AND I WANTED A STRAIGHT ANSWER
FROM YOU.
DO REPUBLICANS, DO YOU WANT TO
REPEAL THE INFLATION REDUCTION
ACT.
>> I HOPE WE CAN DO UNDO AS
MUCH AS POSSIBLE ESPECIALLY THE
87,000 NEW IRS AGENTS.
JACQUI: UNDERSTOOD.
CONGRESSWOMAN ASHLEY HINSON,
THANK YOU FO